aujourd'hui face à vous toute l'équipe
de la chasse aux trésors cette émission
qui passe le dimanche après midi vers 18
heures sur antenne 2 en tête de cette
équipe le producteur jacques antoine
j'avoue est déjà venu nous expliquer
comment se passer cette émission comment
vous l'aviez imaginé comment voulez vous
réalisiez bien maintenant j'aimerais que
vous nous présentiez vos principaux
collaborateurs car comme toujours il en
manque quelques heures bien sûr le oui
ils manquent eux mêmes un des
collaborateurs essentiel c'est le
caméraman parce que vous verrez je pense
que les téléspectateurs filmés alors ils
manquent pas vraiment voilà qui sera
levé rendant au courant des vues au
cours de l'émission qui joue un rôle
très important s'appelle jean yves le
maner alors mais a bien entendu il ya
philippe gildas philippe de dieuleveult
2 philippe que c'est un peu compliqué
surtout pour des gens qui doivent se
parler au téléphone à l'eau avoue
philippe louis philippe sétois philippe
oui je suis moi aussi j -c phillips et
philippe on n'a pas osé les débaptisés
ensuite il y à jean luc noël qui est un
assistant qui possède repérage à ça tout
à l'heure ainsi que rené de 10 les
réalisateurs jean jacques pasquet et aux
salariés bien alors philippe gildas
d'être le premier qui je posais un
certain nombre de questions parce que
vous êtes celui qui qui fait se poser le
plus de questions aux téléspectateurs on
se demande d'abord pour quelles raisons
vous êtes sans arrêt en train de
discuter de chercher vos papiers sans
jamais regarder de téléviseurs moi je
vous connais la réponse devrait quand
même une fois de plus que vous le disiez
et la section le téléviseur de nouveau
avec moi même où les concurrents qui
sont avec moi mon n'a pas l'image nous
sommes les seuls à ne pas avoir l'image
au fond est ce que vous croyez qu'on
pourrait dire que cette émission de
télévision au départ et lorsque vous la
l'enregistrer n'est qu'un jeu
radiophonique pour un peu oui pour le
pour les candidats et pour moi-même ça
se passe exactement comme un joueur
adulé pour philippe de dieuleveult de la
même façon d'ailleurs puisque
travaillons lui avec le casque sur les
oreilles et moi avec un retour sur le
plateau comme dans un studio de radio et
nous nous entendons plus ou moins bien
d'ailleurs c'est un autre problème parce
que c'est souvent très très loin et je
me souviens de certaines émissions en
afrique du sud ou bien aux américains ou
les liaisons été assez difficile parce
qu'en plus il ya des problèmes de
décalage horaire et vraiment on ne voit
donc rien puisque techniquement ce
serait pratiquement impossible tout cas
ça coûterait des milliards c'est pas du
tout depuis l'opération donc impossible
de voir l'image en même temps donc nous
nous sommes les seuls à n'avoir que la
liaison son et un son qui n'est pas
toujours fameux si bien que la moitié de
mon travail a consisté à essayer
d'écouter et de traduire et notamment
pour les non seulement pour les
téléspectateurs
mais surtout pour les concurrents qui
sont dans les mêmes conditions coin et
qui en plus ont le gros désavantage est
obligé de lire de rechercher de penser
et ça paraît idiot à dire comme ça mais
c'est très difficile de d'écouter
quelque chose de difficile d'entendre et
de lire et de sa propre a commencé dans
cinq ans vous êtes surtout intermédiaire
entre dieu le veut et les candidats
alors que vous jouez vous avez le droit
de jouer au cours de cette émission je
crois j'ai le droit de jouer dans la
mesure où je ne vois rien je suis donc
exactement la même condition que les
j'avais le couple qui joue mais en plus
je peux jouer parce que je ne sais rien
non plus je ne sais je ne connais ni
lait ni ne serait pas drôle
si jusque là c'est l'énigme et je crois
que je pourrais même pas faire
l'émission à ce moment là parce que j'ai
je pourrais pas qu'à l'émission si je
connais c'est l'énigme parce que je ne
pourrai pas les aider du tout donc je
serai un simple relais mécanique
je serai très gêné j'aurais peur de
l'est de les conduire dans un mauvais
dans une mauvaise direction
alors que l' avantage de ne rien savoir
c'est qu'effectivement ça donne envie de
jouer et de gagner avec eux et de les
voir gagner
quels sont les impératifs de 7,2 cette
émission vous ne faites pas ailleurs
fixe je crois ça ça doit être un
problème tout de même vous êtes de
l'enregistrer au moment où il fait jour
ça je crois que c'est un autre problème
je sais que jacques a déjà beaucoup
répondu la team je crois qu'on peut leur
dire une fois de plus c'est une émission
qui est diffusée en différé mais qui
s'enregistrent vraiment dans les
conditions du direct
ensuite on ne fait que mélanger les
images tournées de deux côtés c'est sur
le plateau à paris et avec philippe de
dieuleveult et son équipe sur le terrain
donc on va mélanger ensuite c'est le
seul travail c'est à dire qu'on mélange
deux images mais dans la durée réelle ça
a été enregistré en une heure ça se
retourne exactement comme une émission
de direct
et alors le résultat c'est
qu'effectivement avec le décalage
horaire et bien quand on s'en va en
arizona on a neuf heures de décalage
donc les gens vont nous voir à 17 à 18
heures le
dimanche mais en fait on a très bien pu
enregistrer à 23 heures le soir parce
que ça correspondait la meilleure heure
pour le soleil et pour l'équipe mais mes
camarades nous expliquerons dans quelles
conditions ils déterminent la bonne
heure de tournage
est ce qu'on en a fait d'autres plus on
s'en va vers l'est puis on tourne dans
le matin c'est dans l'autre sens les
autres impératif que vous avez vous êtes
quand même un petit peu tenu d'attendre
que tout se passe bien techniquement sur
le lieux extérieurs à l'étranger les
vraies difficultés mais là encore c'est
pas mon problème à moi c'est pas mon
problème des animateurs c'est le
problème de toute l'équipe les vrais
c'est bien pire pour les producteurs
ailleurs jacky est à côté
mentionnons plus de crayons en bois que
moi celle du souci des fois il nous est
arrivé quand même d'avoir la liaison
cinq minutes avant l'émission et ça se
passait à l'autre bout du monde
et puis d'avoir une rupture de liaison
téléphonique était un simple petit pépin
téléphonique
mais il faut six heures pour le réparer
or six heures quand ils sont en plein
soleil par 40° au zimbabwe c'est une
catastrophe
de notre côté nous on peut attendre si
cela vous fassiez très agréable vous
parlez sans heurt des angoisses du
producteur mais et vos concurrents ils
doivent comme c'est un métier de jouer
presque elle pour la télé c'est un jeu
quand même et je crois que tous les
concurrents nous avons vu jusqu'ici joué
vraiment en certains sondages sont un
peu plus nerveux
or on a vu une dame effectivement qui a
failli giflé son mari pendant toute
l'émission parce que ça se voyait
pratiquement elle prétendait que c'était
de sa faute si elle allait perdre
elle a fini par perdre d'ailleurs et on
a vu une autre qui s'est effondré à la
fin d'émission on a vu des hommes qui
étaient incapables de parler
effectivement pendant une émission mais
ça c'est l' angoisse du jeu
c'est vrai je crois pour tous je sais
c'est pas le sait pas le plus dramatique
je pense le plus difficile effectivement
celle angoisses de l'équipe qui réalise
et qui à établir à chaque fois cette
performance assez incroyable au fait qui
m'étonne moi toujours c'est que déjà on
sait bien qu'en télévision radio on peut
avoir dépassé un kilomètre de distance
mais quand ça se fait par le teil relais
par un simple téléphone et à six sept ou
huit mois j'admire beaucoup les i c'est
aussi l'équipe il ya qui réalise ça à
chaque fois et le producteur qui a eu
l'idée un peu dingue à mon avis le de
tenter ce pari à chaque émission parce
que c'est un pari qu'on peut perdre à
chaque fois mais c'est quand même une
idée superbe allait super bien et comme
allant là comme joueur puisque je suis
autant jouer en qu'animateur sur sa
formidable
philippe de dieuleveult vous vous êtes
celui qui est ailleurs qui est à
l'étranger et qui donne aussi beaucoup
et qui joue aussi beaucoup parce que je
le précise encore il ya très peu de
genre et je les présenterai tout à
l'heure qui sont au courant de l'énigme
vous vous partez là bas vous ne savez
rien qu'en lorsque je monte dans les
commentaires c'est pour aller se mettre
en place pour la première image jean
falala obligé en place qu'est ce que ça
veut dire et je pense que les
producteurs choisissent à un paysage qui
sera quand même assez agréable oui à
voir parce qu'au début d'émission savait
que les candidats cherchent dans les
bouquins qui sont un petit peu perdues
donc dans ce cas là on a en démarrant
déjà une très belle image du
d'hélicoptères moi je vends
d'hélicoptères et puis je découvre
complètement des glycols table 10
allaient à tel endroit j'y vais avec le
plus grand plaisir parce que maintenant
en plus dans la joute écoutez vous êtes
bien écouter ce que vous demande
philippe oui alors y aller le plus vite
alors bien écoutez c'est également à
gros problème parce que les liaisons ne
sont pas toujours très bonnes c'est vrai
et donc le sage et le bruit de
l'hélicoptère qui est quand même assez
infernal m'occuper de pilote de la carte
éventuellement d'une boussole de
vérifier cette caméraman suis bien
derrière si la casse était bien dans les
dents métaux fins de ce que bien sûr
dans le mato scop si elle n'y est pas il
faudra à ce que la coupe est un petit
pays est interrompue fier vouliez dire
quelque chose s'est elle est là oui non
je voulais dire que les débuts les
premières émissions étaient disons un
petit peu pour tout le monde une grande
aventure
maintenant c'est toujours une grande
aventure mais c'est une ambiance dans
l'hélicoptère qui est fantastique parce
que jean yves le maner vous le disiez
j'ai déjà contrainte à l'heure est
formidable mais il ya eu un grand bruit
au delattre
francis ciment et thierry coup on va les
voir tout à l'heure quand on a un petit
film sur un de vos tournages en fibres
je vais vous demander est ce que vous
vous êtes vous êtes angoissé inquiet
serein tranquille parce que tout de même
présenter ou plutôt courir ce tout au
long de l'ingestion ça va très vite je
ne suis pas angoissé parce que c'est pas
compliqué ce qu'on me demande on demande
obéit autant que les souvenirs c'est pas
si mal et si c'est vrai je vais je
montre dans l'hélicoptère aller à tel
endroit je regarde la carte auquel
pilotes on y verra ça me semble évident
moi je serai présent mais non celle ci
n'était pas sourd ça sera pas un
problème mais il est souvent un sourd
est-ce que quelques fois vous avez eu
peur parce que toute neuve vers des
endroits où on vous attend pas toujours
on vous fait faire tout de même des
balades dans des dents des dans des
lieux un petit peu impressionnant je
pense que mon caractère est fait pour
pour ce jeu moi je m'amuse je m'amuse
beaucoup et j'ai envie d'aller justement
là où je ne sais pas ce qui va se passer
de dire tout et là vous êtes un ancien
la course autour du monde sait cela et
qui a été repêché dans cette émission
vous étiez déjà au journal sur antenne 2
quoi je travaille comme journaliste
d'image depuis trois angles il ya
maintenant je voudrais demander aux
assistants et qui ont un rôle très
important sur cette émission de me dire
un petit peu comment ça se passe d'abord
la question qu'on se pose toujours c'est
nous quand on est devant nos décideurs
dans notre récepteur tout est fait à
quel moment commencez-vous à travailler
sur une émission
moi je te parle un peu plus que rené
parce qu'il est un peu et la pointe de
gorge oui 2 vous faites la même chose me
fait rien c'est à dire que rené s'occupe
de l'équipe qui travaille avec claude
savary et que je m'occupe de celles qui
travaillent que jean-luc pasquier qui
partira ensuite sur le tournage
notre problème c'est de
d'aller sur place de repérer les lieux
où vont se dérouler les missions à
partir de lening qui ont été préparés à
paris avec jacques antoine oui c'est
donc d'aller sur place et d'être sûr que
tout va fonctionner que on pourra se
poser à tel endroit et que les lieux
correspondent bien aux textes préparés
c'est vous qui monte le jeu de piste sur
place en quelque sorte une préparation
du jeu de pieds sur pouvoir vérifier que
tout ce qui a été imaginé par jacques
antoine et c'est ça correspond bien la
reine briser l'image qu'on avait à paris
là vous faites donc voit un premier
voyage bien avant l'émission bien avant
l'émission pour aller sur place avec
leurs fins les choses qu'on a réuni à
paris on a relu dans les livres et c'est
toute une documentation mais ça
correspond rarement à ce qu'il ya sur
place il faut donc souvent arranger un
petit peu et puis revenir avec jacques
en reparler avec jacques et puis à ce
moment là les autres sont prêts à partir
est ce que c'est à ce moment là que vous
déposez le trésor absolument déjà la
personne n'est venu le nom de par hasard
non j'ai pas encore arrivé on vous prie
chaque fois pour que ça n'arrive pas
bien et vous faites la même chose mais
alors vas y que jean-luc avec donc je
fais équipe avec claude savary et donc
c'est en général j'en ai ne l'a pas dit
mais c'est un mois et demi deux mois
avant que les émissions ne se réalise
vraiment qu'il faut donc aller dans le
pays pour vérifier que j'aurais vous me
préciser tous les deux le jour de
l'enregistrement de l'émission dont vous
vous êtes occupés vous n'êtes jamais
là-bas vous êtes dans la mare sur
d'abord ferme à paris nous sommes avant
compagnie de jacques antoine sur le sur
le studio avec donc ses serres les
candidats inscrits plus tard alors que
vous deux les réalisateurs en contraire
vous partez avec l'équipe qui est à
l'extérieur à l'étranger alors que de
savoir et j'aimerais d'abord que vous
m'expliquer ce que cela représente comme
organisation comme travail pour un
réalisateur d'être sur le point
extérieur par rapport aux studios
d'abord je sais vous m'avez préparé
pendant le week-end un petit dessin oui
j'ai besoin de vous nous manquiez pour
qu'enfin on comprennent clairement je
vous ai préparé un petit dessin parce
qu'il pleut on dit souvent qu'un petit
croquis vaut mieux qu'un grand discours
pour vous expliquer justement répondre à
des questions comment ça fonctionne et
est ce que je vais faire sur place avec
l'équipe technique
si vous voulez symbolisée ici de ce côté
ci du dessin nous avons paris le sur
paris avec philippe et les deux
candidats et
sur ce côté ci de l'image j'ai marqué
l'australie pour bien marquer que nous
sommes loin
vous savez convaincre et loin combat à
l'autre bout du monde et là il ya
l'équipe extérieur symbolisée par
évidemment l'hélicoptère et philippe de
dieuleveult
alors s'il veut vous adaptez déjà
remarqué dans l'émission il a une espèce
de poisson
il a une petite boîte noire sur la
poitrine avec une antenne c'est un
émetteur récepteur de radio
lorsqu'il parle dans son micro ces
thèmes et aux récepteurs envoie sa voix
dans un
relais radio qui se trouve dans un petit
avion léger qui vole au dessus de lui
qui fait des rondes séduit parce qu'en
plus de l'hélicoptère vous dire
l'aviation qui est un relais radio de
cet avion la voix de philippe va partir
vers un point haut ce que nous appelons
notre station de basket une une grande
antenne que nous installons sur le lieu
d'émission disons dans un point élevé
pour obtenir la meilleure liaison
possible au point de vue radio et à cet
endroit là au pied de cette antenne
eh bien nous avons un téléphone tout
bêtement un téléphone et ce téléphone
il est relié au studio à paris c'est ça
la grande salle à la grande astuce c'est
qui ce passe un jeu au téléphone au
téléphone bien entendu philippe de
dieuleveult ne sait pas trop ce qui se
passe à paris si ce n'est que parce que
l'édifice gildas est en revanche
philippe gildas ne voit rien il ne sait
que ses huit départs contre jacques pin
lorsque cette voie qui est passé par son
petit émetteur l'avion la station relais
de base et de la ligne téléphonique
alors elle qui peut nous ramener depuis
l'australie par exemple sur ce dessin
jusqu'au sur boulogne est bien là
arrivent ici dans un rôle dans un
haut-parleur et philippe gildas et ses
deux concurrents entendre fort bien par
ce haut parleur à l'avoir chez pagnol à
chaque fois cette année mais c'est vrai
que le renouveler de tout c'est vrai que
j'aurais dû ajouter tout à l'heure que
le l'une des grandes difficultés
effectivement c'est que lui d'une part
ne voit pas d'un même pas idée de la
tête qu'on les concurrents et il va
découvrir les concurrents le jour où
l'émission est diffusée sur antenne 2
d'ailleurs c'était à moi qu'il est
tournée mais il est qu il les voit même
pas mais téléspectateurs et nous en
plateau sur les candidats vont voir les
images en même temps que moi à la
télévision quand ils verront gagner ou
perdre mais nous n'avons rien vu avant
absolument rien vu
claude savard et comment vous rendez
vous sur les lieux du jeu je vais vous
surprendre on y va en avion en yvan
l'avion mais avec un avion un peu
particulier parce que nous louons un
petit jet
ça semble un peu dur au départ mais en
fait les courses ont bien fait c'est
comme la chose là
la plus pas moins onéreuse pour
transporter à la fois tout ce modèle
vous voyez sur l'image maintenant ces
stations relais de radio la station de
base radio car si le matériel est roi
qui m'ont les gens ce qui concerne le
caméraman est l'homme du magnétoscope et
le petit relais radio de philippe de
dieuleveult la station de base et le
relais radio qui sera dans le petit
avion qui va survoler l'ensemble de
l'émission c'est quand même beaucoup de
matériel c'est pratiquement 700 kg de
matériel alors nous embarquons tout ce
matériel et l'équipe technique dans ce
petit gadget vous voyez il est 5 heures
du matin au projet on va partir et toute
cette équipe par pour un pays lointain
qu'en général elles n'a jamais découvert
ou connus avant et ne sait absolument
pas ce que sera li ning ce que sera le
présent à chercher on part dans la nuit
en plein brouillard pour l'autre bout du
monde
évidemment on disait tout à l'heure il
manque un certain nombre de vos
collaborateurs certes émission ce sont
ces fameux homme de l'équipe technique
qui est sur place à l'étranger alors
vous avez très gentiment à porter un
film où vous nous les présenter les uns
les autres j'aimerais qu'on les voit
maintenant oui c'est un film qui a été
fait par nos amis de liu xin la
télévision suisse et qui nous avait
filmé un jour voilà pour la chasse au
trésor alors c'est peut-être je crois le
moment de vous montrer à la fois ceux
qui sont devant la caméra et derrière la
caméra ce que vous ne voyez pas alors il
y a tout d'abord bien entendu le pilote
d'hélicoptère le pilote d'hélicoptère
c'est jojo projet qui est suisse puisque
nous sommes à nation et qui avec son
hélicoptère va nous emmener partout les
candidats le demanderont merci jo nous
avons évidemment philippe de dieuleveult
le reporter lui vous le connaissez bien
vous le voyez à toutes les émissions
il est l'homme qui court l'homme qui
cherchait trésor pour les candidats mais
avec lui il y a deux garçons très
important c'est ce qu'ils font l'image
ya jean yves jean yves le maner que vous
voyez d'habitude au début de l'émission
que je vous présente avec sa caméra et
nous avons patrick simon patrick simon
qui lui est en charge de tout ce qui est
le francis immo qui est en charge de du
de tout ce qui vit d eau du bain de ska
partie de vous que lorsque vous voyez
philippe courir eh bien il ya derrière
jean yves et francis qui courent eux
aussi derrière et ils sont ils sont en
plus chargées de cette caméra et de sa
bêta scop le aussi l'espace portiques
pour eux n'est pas une petite affaire
et lorsque nous avons fini avec l'image
est bien il ya maintenant le problème du
sur le problème du son c'est la liaison
entre l'hélicoptère à philippe de
dieuleveult partout où ils se trouvent
et lesieu de paris
les candidats et philippe gildas et bien
cette saison est assurée par patrick qui
lui assure tout ce qui est liaison radio
avec une station de base qui se trouve
là aujourd'hui à savièse au dessus de la
au dessus de la région de sion et entre
l'hélicoptère et la station de savièse
kiss à qui elle est liée à paris par une
liaison téléphonique normal
nous avons un avion un avion relais pour
permettre que la lisons surface toujours
bien entre l'hélicoptère et celle
station de savièse et dans cet avion qui
est piloté par petter théorie suisse
comme le pilote d'hélicoptère dans la
vie on paie terre il ya une station
radio relais voilà tout le système tel
qu'il se présente c'est un système assez
lourd mais fiable et qui nous permet
chaque semaine doit être dans un pays
différent tout autour du monde pour
faire cette chasse au trésor un jour n'a
d'ailleurs en suisse nos amis la
télévision suisse avait un deuxième
hélicoptère et ils ont filmé notre
hélicoptère pendant toute l'émission ils
ont littéralement suivi comme des chiens
de chasse pendant les 45 minutes du jeu
as you are vous voyez l'hélicoptère et
sur son aire de départ prêt à partir
avec philippe le pilote et le cameraman
jean yves le maner et francis simon no
numa et ascot
ils sont partis ils montent à près de
3000 mètres d'altitude avec ce petit
point blanc qui monte au dessus du
barrage c'est l'hélicoptère il franchi
le barrage de la grande dixence est
maintenant sur les ordres des candidats
il se rend vers un autre lieu qui je
crois va être le château de valère dans
la vallée au pied de ce magnifique
massif des alpes alors vous voyez la
caméra de la caméra de
jean yves le maner qui filment en
permanence car la caméra n'arrête pas de
tourner n'arrête pas de filmer pendant
toute la durée du jeu et on arrive à
proximité du château de valeurs ou les
candidats ont demandé à philippe de
dieuleveult d'intérêt pour essayer de
quémander d'avoir quelques
renseignements sur l'histoire de la
région pour essayer d'être où se trouve
le trésor l'hélicoptère est posée là
l'image est très intéressante parce que
voyez je suis dit p sorties il court il
court dans la neige mais il n'est pas
seul
ils sont trois derrière lui il ya jean
yves le maner